[Music]
don't want to be late do I have to go
it's the only day I get to play games
we're all going come on don't understand
why we have to go to church every Sunday
church is important Stan way more
important than video games and TV Church
is about community and coming together a
lot of things all I know is that after
church I just feel better yeah me too
[Music]
hey morning Steven Linda morning guys
thanks there Randy you got it where's
Josie
now oh she slipped her disc in her neck
poor thing can barely move ah she's into
Miss Church that's too bad give her my
best for God so loved the world that He
gave His only begotten Son so that
whoever believed in him should have
eternal life this is the gospel of the
Lord
today's gospel talks about what the Lord
has to give us he did so because we
could not control our temptations kind
of like a priest in a room full of naked
boys okay okay let's let's try and have
none of that today in John 3:16 the
gospel tells us how God so loved the
world he gave to us His only Son and a
Catholic priest raped him come on guys
now what greater gift could the Lord
have given to us children's underwear
which priests couldn't pull down so
easily let's try and just get through
this first one okay guys what does it
mean that the Lord gave us his only
begotten Son it means if you're a cute
boy at a Catholic priest swimming party
you better begin
[Laughter]
[Applause]
haha I was a great one Nelson Salvation
in a little boy's mouth I'm gonna post
that one for sure who said the thing
about naked boy salad oh that was Linda
well see you next week everybody I
[Applause]
really don't understand the point of all
that yeah well I used to think that
about church when I was a kid too but
back then I don't know if church was
that stupid hey don't say things like
that Stan you want to go to hell
you